hey guys welcome to gamescom 2015 I'm
Dave I'm here with two more you've been
doing some sijan you've been bean
decision hard rainbow six siege as a new
business i know i don't think so i think
you see way more than six times well
that's the hope otherwise you would suck
to have a problem salon seizures yeah so
I played an early build of the game I
think it's just pre beta beta starts in
a few weeks but they still locking in
content so some of the stuff I saw was a
bit shaky like animations were a bit
wonky and guns were floating in the sky
sometimes when you fell down but what I
played was really really interesting now
you and I are both seasoned countless
right players so I try to apply some of
my counter strike knowledge to it and
found pleasantly but not not a lot of it
served me very well oh yeah the
comparison that love you been drawing
saying hey you son this looks a lot like
counter-strike it you just a bunk that
it does look a lot account right claim
it functions a lot like contract but
what counter-strike has is the way I see
it is like you reach a point when you
play counter-strike nothing changes in
there in the environment around you know
you've got your cell big stretch yeah
dust is always dust so you could sit
there for a month learn every strap
every angle know all the line of sight
and you're pretty much good then it's
just down to your dexterity and your
reaction times the thing with this game
is it's very very disruptive or every
environment is destructible it's very
tight and then multi-layered so you've
got really think about what around you
how can someone use that as a way to
even disrupt your strategy or approach
from different way so what happened with
me was I played both sides so initially
I was defending and then I was on the
offense so and we were in this in this
weird bunker thai place which was like
pot house part weird underground bunker
thing clearly some weird stuff had
happened there right like terrorists
were there the negotiation always moved
in yeah they were kind of moving in and
down yeah they have like weird stopped
set up downstairs then you go in guns
blazing and the other team needs to
defend so I was defending and there was
a lot of like wooden walls that because
there wouldn't someone could just stand
on the other side and listen out for you
and shoot through them so my my
operative
had the ability to reinforce the walls
say stuff like that remember figuring
out all these a window behind me that
could potentially be a line of sight for
someone and so I need to plug it up or
you could be like what I'm going to do
is I'm going to plug up these doors so
that your kind of tricking you're trying
to guide and using an invisible hand the
player to a choke point that you've set
up it's basically about creating a shell
around yourself and then trying to hold
the position for as long as possible I
see but the cool thing was there was
like a whole bunch of different
operatives to like from different parts
of the world different like military
style is that kind of thing but each had
a unique weapon loadout and they each
had a good like specific role and what
would happen was you'd pick that but you
could only have one of them at a time in
our build anyway so if you had the guy
who's really good at breaking down
fortifications no one else could pick
him but I mean it meant that you had to
kind of really think about your
composition and try and build your
strategy around it so we had when we
were on the attack we had a guy who had
a very large shield and in the kind of
like scouting mode when you first start
you don't just start and go with it and
get a little chance to like guide these
little drones around and see where this
up right so in that mode we saw where
they were and then they had clearly set
up this kind of like choke point for us
so what our strategy was to pick the guy
with a big shield and also take the girl
with a smaller shield let them leave the
charge hide behind them and just kind of
like pop out and keep taking potshots
like police based Romans exactly that is
exactly what it was and will I lobbing
whoever had a grenade could chuck a
grenade over the target and then what
will happen what was happening was we
quickly realized that the they will
focus it in focusing in on us because we
had the two shields they couldn't break
through so the most of the team started
gathering around us which was the
perfect opportunity for one of us to
break away and flank and he flanked by
going around like busting through it was
a guy who's capable of blasting through
fortifications went round broke through
a window came downstairs and caught
everyone facing the two shielded guys
and just like laid into them and kill
almost
it's really really interesting it's
basically like there is no specific line
of sight you need to think about whether
enemies can break in from where you're
looking maybe behind you above you
there's a bit where a bomb went off and
like the ceiling started collapsing on
itself and I was like damn I need to
keep an eye on that just in case someone
can check another bomb in there and
while I'm preoccupied to drop down
behind me see it's just super dynamic
super interesting and like as a Counter
Strike fan it's good to have a game
where not everything is tagged every
time you come back there it's dynamic
things are changing everyone has their
own style of play you're never just
running to a B and just you know smoking
the same way every time we're just
hoping that you're quicker than the
other person it's like they're trying to
focus on kind of keeping the same maps
in the same formula yeah but having lots
of replayability exactly it seems like
there's ok so you ain't in one strategy
you're a strategy can be encountered by
avatar this is a key and then you coulda
can hear strategy quickly it kind of
feels like it's going to mean that no
two games are going to be the same
because your level destructive in it
because of the options you have caused
the team compositions you have it's
going to be able to build what you want
do what you want yeah because there's
obviously the good guys and the bad guys
it's an asymmetrical shooter how they
balance this it's difficult to tell
about balance because I had one go on
each side it's difficult to tell whether
the guns how they stack up against each
other and how operatives kind of work
when you're going up against someone
who's naturally you're you know you be
kind of counterpoint to you whether
there is an imbalance or a balance and
how like even if there's some
overpowered strategies I think that's
one of the things that they all address
as the game is out there and evolves I
think the thinking of it like a they
taking the eSports route like this game
is built for eSports to the point where
they've introduced a brand new spectator
mode so as well as having the first
person mode they've done like a top-down
mode so you can see the entire map and
you can see where people are going and
it's put partly because they want people
to watch it through you sports but also
because they want people to watch it and
learn so like balancing and stuff like
that is going to be very reactive I
they treated like something like
daughter something like string fight
where when people figure out exploits
they'll discuss whether they want to
patch it maybe figure out some
alternative balancing ish methods and
then go from there it's a very dynamic
kind of like living breathing game you
get me excited for this game I can't
wait to play it means more going to go
bump it down and reinforce our apartment
if you want to see more on Rainbow six
siege you can keep it tuned in gamespot
you